Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the audience.
We are going to take some calls via Discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord last week
brought us an almost unblemished slate of calls,
both from a content standpoint and
an audio quality standpoint. We're
going to try to keep that going this week.
Let's go next to Eric from Cancun. Eric,
you're on the air.
Speaker 5: I mean,
how are you? Call your. Mr Call you, sir, if
I told The Daily Caller the title, because
that's how you call me last time we
talk and I'm also. Many of the viewers,
like the last time we talked and I talked
to my relatives and friends about it,
and here's what I'm thinking now. You
think it would be better to deduct taxes
or charities because and paying the
IRS directly, because the way because
to support these charities and the causes, I do
care about them because they would not totally
trust the politicians with what they do with
their money in the money is what this country.
Speaker 1: Eric, let me see if I understand
you're saying instead of paying taxes to the IRS,
just donate money to charities instead.
Speaker 5: It's mostly because it is still
on the board of the charities I do care about then
also because I have led some trust since then.
Speaker 1: No, I understand, Eric, I don't
need you. I'm just asking is am I understanding
correctly what you said? You're saying instead
of taxes to the IRS? Donate to charity.
Speaker 5: And mostly looking are leads only
to charities, but I know that because I would
not trust my team politicians.
Speaker 1: No, I understand. I
don't need you to. I'm just I'm just
trying to make sure I understand.
So who pays for the roads if instead
of taxes, we donate to charity?
Speaker 5: And. And I wouldn't say
that Jews should pay some taxes to IRS,
but mostly to charities. OK.
Speaker 1: All right, Eric,
thank you for the call. I very much appreciate it